and the talk is about practical Dynamic
graph algorithms data structures and
connections between models
please yeah
thank you for the introduction
so today I will be talking about
practical Dynamic graph algorithms and
specifically several models for which
come up with the algorithms that can be
easily transferred between these models
and because I'll be talking about
several models for the presentation I
will start
by introducing these models so we're in
a dynamic graphs Workshop so everybody
knows the sequential Dynamic model so
this is a classic Model where you have
Edge insertions and deletions that
arrive sequentially and you want to
maintain a graph property after each
Edge insertion and deletion
there are several variants of this model
that look at a variety of aspects
so you can think of various ways to
represent the graph
you can also have different types of
resources to process the graph
in addition to how to maintain your
graph in memory and how to process these
graphs you can also have different ways
to obtain the updates for the graph
and finally you can have various
adversarial models
um
and so let's go through each of these
one by one
okay so there are several ways to
represent your graph you can store your
graph on one machine
or you can partition your graph across
many machines and the machines talk to
each other via some communication
Network
if you store your graph on one machine
you can process the graph using multiple
course and multiple processors on your
machine
so nowadays we're dealing with machines
with many more than one core even your
laptop has at least eight cores nowadays
and for these cores they can process
parts of your graph in parallel and read
and write from as the same shared main
memory
only nowadays one of the models that we
use to study such a system is the shared
memory work depth model
there are various other models that have
been used like the pram model
historically
but the work depth model consists of two
complexity measures the work which is
the total number of operations that is
that is done by your algorithm
and the depth or the span uh which is
the longest chain of sequential
dependencies in your algorithm
now you have more than one machine
you now have a distributed Network
uh and one of the ways uh one of the
models that model is the distributed
network is the massively parallel
computation model or the MPC model
and this model has been supported by a
large companies who have many machines
to process their large data so Google is
one of these companies that heavily
pushes this model
and this model consists of M machines
which talk to each other via synchronous
rounds
so here are your n m machines
uh and your graph is partitioned across
these machines
specifically the edges of your graph are
partition across these machines
now the machines each have s space
generally you want s to be linear in the
the number of nodes in your graph not in
the number of edges
uh and even better is when you have
sublinear memory per machine so
sublinear number of nodes per machine
and you can do some local computation in
your machine and the machines talk to
each other
via a fully connected communication
Network
so another complexity measure that you
care about is a total space which is M
times s
in the complexity measure that we
specifically care about in this model is
the total space
the space for machine and the number of
rounds of communication
so here are the two models on how to
process the graphs using these models uh
the other question is how are the
updates given to our Dynamic graph
when you're given updates sequentially
you're given updates one at a time
but if you're a lot of of these updates
happen at the same time you can bash
together the updates uh in batches of
multiple updates
so we generally talk about the batch
Dynamic model in this case
um and the number of previous presenters
have talked about the batch Dynamic
model
um and the batch diama model is you're
given some graph uh and you're given a
batch of updates
so the batch of updates consists of
insertions and deletions
and then after you're given this batch
of updates you obtain a final graph
so this final graph is obtained after
you perform all of your insertions of
your deletions
in addition to processing the graph
using a batch another way that your
graph could be represented is as a
stream of edge updates
so this is your input graph your input
graph could come as a stream of edges
where you have some amount of small
memory to store parts of your stream
so this is again dealing with a very
large graph you don't have enough memory
to store all of your graph but instead
you can store a part of your graph
so you're given these edges one at a
time
and you can choose to store some number
of these edges in your memory for
whichever problem you want to process
so you're given the stream and you store
parts of the Stream
and the relevant complexity measures in
this model is the total memory that
you're using to store your store
whichever part of the stream you want to
store and the number of passes
through the Stream
that you need for your problem
okay and then finally you have your
adversarial models so we've heard about
the Adaptive oblivious adversary models
this is just as a reminder uh the
oblivious adversary has no knowledge of
your previous algorithm outputs for your
previous updates so your abilities
adversary you can just think of as a
offline adversary uh where they compute
some number of updates before you run
the algorithm but the updates come to
you online so you're given these updates
online but they're they're predetermined
before they see the outputs of your
algorithm
now for the Adaptive app Siri these
adaptive app series can see the previous
algorithm outputs and sometimes you can
even assume that your adaptive out
series can see the internal bits
of your algorithm so specifically if
your algorithm is deterministic you're
uh robust against this strongest version
of adaptive adversary
and even stronger adversaries um you can
consider to be adversaries that violate
the privacy of your algorithm
um and for these privacy uh violating
adversaries you can have two different
types you can have the central model of
differential privacy in which your
private graph is given to some trusted
curator
The Trusted curator is responsible for
uh coming up with a private algorithm
for which they output privatized answers
to queries
so the golden sander for um for
protecting the privacy of these users is
via differential privacy and different
privacy is you're given some randomized
algorithm a and it is Epsilon
differentially private if there are all
pairs of neighboring inputs gng Prime
and all sorts of possible outputs
your algorithm outputs
um an element of this output with
approximately equal probability
so Epsilon is your is your privacy
parameter so smaller Epsilon means the
difference between your probabilities is
smaller larger Epsilon means you're
allowed larger difference between your
probabilities
and this neighboring inputs is the
things you're you're trying to hide
and for graphs we often talk about Edge
neighboring graphs so you'll want to
hide the presence of any Edge in your
graph so for Edge labeling graphs they
differ by exactly one Edge
okay so that's most of the previous
results are in the central model of DP
more recently what's become more popular
is that this local model of differential
privacy so the central model you're
assuming your private graph is given to
some Central algorithm private algorithm
but the central coordinator knows your
entire private graph
now this is not the case for local
privacy so for local privacy you're
assuming each of your nodes
contains some form of a private
algorithm so we can say each of these
nodes has some Epsilon local randomizer
R and this Epsilon local randomizer is
an Epsilon differentially private
algorithm
and what this Epsilon local randomizer
takes as input is uh an adjacency list
which is private so its own adjacency
list
and some publing information and outputs
privatized
answers
so
um the neighboring inputs in this case
are the adjacency lists so a neighboring
input is adjacency list that differs
exactly one bit
yeah using this uh local randomizer you
can now
use a distributed algorithm
on your notes
so the way that distributed algorithm
works is that the algorithm can proceed
in several rounds uh interactive rounds
where the nodes talk to some untrusted
curator
now the nodes now are outputting
privatized answers
so now we don't have to trust the trust
the curator with their private adjacency
List information
so you just need some curator you don't
have to trust them they just need to do
some coordination on the algorithm
so in each round the coordinator sends
some public information to the nodes so
let's say this public information is X
and then each node uses their private
adjacency list
passes it as input into their private uh
local randomizer algorithm
and then I'll put some privatized
information back to the curator
Now using those private information
the carried our can produce some new
public information
pass it back to the nodes
the nodes now use their private
information and this new public
information to produce some additional
outputs send it back to the curator and
so on and you can use this via several
rounds of the algorithm
and because we're talking about this
um the relevant complexity measure that
we care about here is the number of
rounds of communication as with any
distributed algorithm
and the relevant comparison is to
non-private distributed algorithms so
here I've described the model in terms
of a curator so some of these algorithms
you can have as purely distributed where
each of the nodes are only sending
messages to their neighbors so each of
the nodes are only sending privatized
information to their neighbors but it's
easier to Define it in terms of a
central untrusted curator
okay so this is a very strong notion of
privacy uh where individuals trust
nobody with their private information
um and again the private info that we
want to keep private is any Edge in the
input graph
okay yes
if you allow the curator to return
messages that are customized to each
node in the graph instead of a common
message
ah
question you can you can all carriers to
to return different messages so one way
to think about about this is if you're
in the point-to-point message model
where you're only sending your
privatized information to your neighbors
you're receiving customized information
from your neighbors so you can instead
think of this as the characters uh
returning back to you customize
information so you can definitely have
this as part of your model
um but the return information is based
off of privatized information
so it's a but not everyone sees the
message that you get yes but everybody
sees the message you assume that
everybody can see the message if they
try hard enough
always yes so even if you uh return
privatize even if you return
personalized messages to each node
you're still assuming that if other
people are curious and try hard enough
they can see your
message oh so then you might as well
give it a union of all the messages to
everybody exactly you might as well
broadcast all the messages I see yes
because
just a quick question are you allowed to
use cross run I just said least that's
if you're in round two can you go back
and reuse the business ah yes um so
that's a great clarifying question so
um we assume that adjacency less uh it's
constant throughout the rounds so it's a
static graph
for this model
um we don't currently have a model
that's a local privacy Plus what's
called a continual release model I
actually talk about the continual
release model so that's a dynamic model
but for this local model is it is static
so the graph is fixed at the beginning
and you're Computing the rounds over a
fixed graph so adjacency list stays the
same across uh the rounds but you're
assuming that people keep track of the
information they receive in each round
so in the next round you can see the
information from previous rounds there
are sent and received
okay we're great questions
um
so given these models uh you can also
combine the models to produce
new models uh so for example you can
combine batch Dynamic with the shared
memory work depth model
where you're using these shared memory
processors to process each batch in
parallel you also combine batch Dynamic
with the MPC model
um you can combine Dynamic with
differential privacy and this gives you
the continual release model
and continual releases every single time
you receive an update you want to Output
privatized outputs for your problem
after every update
you can combine distributed with
differential privacy which I've talked
about and that gives you the local model
and of course for streaming you can have
insertion only streams so incremental
Dynamic algorithms
uh or you can have fully Dynamic streams
so combining fully Dynamic updates with
receiving these updates in the Stream
and there are many more
types of models like there are some
interests in combining parallel with
streaming so you care about the amount
of processing time that you're taking
per
for all of the um
edges that you store from the stream
Etc many other different combinations
uh so each model is great for a
different uh real world system but
unfortunately there are a lot of these
models like even just the models
individually there are a lot of these
models once you combine them there's
even more models uh and if I'm actually
implementing these algorithms and
systems I probably don't want to
implement a very a different algorithm
each time my company chooses to
uh update their system
so what I'm going to argue is what we
want to study problems
where we want to find these problems
where the solutions can be implemented
in many models without many changes
so there are a large number of wonderful
Works in each of these models and some
of these Works take inspiration from
other models so I won't be uh talking
about these Works um specifically I'll
be focusing in this presentation on um a
specific problem that I've studied in
some of my works
but if you're interested in these four
other works uh feel free to talk to me
what do I mean by data structures
that you can turn into uh ones that work
in a variety of models
so specifically I mean data structures
that can be modified without much effort
so without much effort is uh is of
course debatable among people but you
can generally think of if you have an
algorithm and you're reviewing the paper
and you think the algorithms
improvements are incremental that is a
good thing in this case
um so
these algorithms are Universal in some
sense
um and what we want is we want the
algorithm to achieve the best known
theoretical guarantees for some of these
models
but for the other models we want the
guarantees to be not much worse than the
best known for these other models
and what's ideal is you want the
theoretical guarantees to be of course
the best theoretical guarantees in as
many models as possible
I mean is there a universal model in
some sense yeah that's a great question
you could just design for this model and
then you can reduce to any other model
that you want yes that's a great
question
um of course we don't know of one now
nowadays but that's definitely the end
goal that we want to go towards it's a
universal model over all of these models
yes
uh but for now I'd say
probably studying the problems for which
we have some solutions that we can
transfer between models is a good
stepping stone towards that end goal
okay so uh how do we do this
um so one specific type of algorithm
I've studied is um what's called this
these locally adjustable graph
algorithms and these graph algorithms
are very simple and you'll see how
simple they are
um and there's some algorithms with some
local structure and what do I mean by
local structure so these algorithms
proceed in a small number of rounds
where in each round each node uses
information from some local neighborhood
you can think of this local neighborhood
as is immediate neighbors even
then during each round each node takes a
small number of actions
so let's take a look at a very simple
type of algorithm that falls under this
this uh category
um so this algorithm we can think of all
the nodes as starting from some initial
state
using this initial State they send some
output some function output on their
initial state to their neighbors
now each of these neighbors counts the
number of function outputs
that satisfy some
constraint
so just counts the number of outputs
that satisfy some constraints based on
this count of outputs that satisfy some
constraints then they update their
internal state
so this node counts the number of their
outputs uh that satisfy some constraints
and then updates their internal state to
S1
now this can proceed in some small
number of rounds where each node updates
a random State based on the function
outputs that we they received from the
previous round
and then sends new function output to
their neighbors and then updates their
state based on this count
and you can do this and so on until the
algorithm terminates so this is
inherently a distributed algorithm uh
some local distributed algorithm uh and
you can think of the nodes that sending
messages to each other via some
point-to-point messages
it turns out these algorithms are very
nice because they can be implemented a
variety of models
and one specific
algorithm class that I'll be talking
about
that falls under this uh this locally
adjustable graph algorithms category are
these level data structures
so there are a lot of algorithms that
use levels
uh still be I'll mostly be talking about
these
uh structures that are very much similar
to each other
um specifically you're partitioning the
vertices uh across the levels and you're
moving these vertices up and down levels
According to some rules
so there are definitely other algorithms
that use levels
um but I won't be talking about those
um and within this class of data
structures I'll focus on this key core
decomposition problem
and this k-core decomposition problem we
have solutions that can be adapted to
all of these models
and the models which are
italicized are the ones for which we
have the best known theoretical solution
or we match the best known theoretical
solution
and for the ones that I've highlighted
in purple I'll be talking about the
results for these
for these models in purple
Okay so
the solutions for this problem called
the key chord composition
and surprisingly this keyboard
composition problem is actually uh much
more well studied in the databases data
mining ml even computational biology
communities
um so you might have heard k core
decomposition from is related problems
which are density subgraphs aversity
degeneracy
um for one reason or other uh all three
of those other concepts are more well
studied in the theory Community than
k-core decomposition so actually a lot
of these are best-known theoretical
papers for cake ordering opposition
actually come from the ldb kdd icml
um so these related adjacent communities
but hopefully we can change that uh
hopefully it'll be more interested in
the theory community on k-core
decomposition specifically
and the cake organization is defined in
terms of this concept called the key
core
so k core is the maximal induced
subgraph where each vertex in this
induced sub graph has degree at least k
but shown in this example the course the
K course in this graph
Now using the course you can assign a
core number of a node V
and the core number is defined as the
maximum K where the k-core contains the
node B
so the maximum value K where the K chord
contains this node
so here is a k-coding composition of all
the nodes in this graph
um and I just want to mention that uh
keyboarding composition is not the same
as a degree of the vertex
um so a very large degree vertex could
have a small
uh k core value
and one one problem with the exact
k-core decomposition definition
um is that there are no differentially
private algorithms for this problem
so there probably does not exist private
algorithms for the exact record
decomposition problem
so if we want to
um obtain these algorithms and also for
exactly core it's very difficult to find
parallel algorithms or distributed
algorithms in small rounds and depth if
you want
if you want algorithms for this problem
we should
relax the problem a bit into the
approximate keyboard
problem
and a c approximate core number exactly
as it sounds it's um it's a one over so
the approximation is lower bounded by
one over c times the exact core number
upper bounded by c times the core number
so this is a two-sided error definition
you can turn it into one-sided by
multiplying C
across
and the specific solution that we have
for approximate key coordinating
opposition is part of this category of
parallel level data structures
um
and there's a variety of these data
structures which have studied arboricity
specifically so obversity low degree
orientation and apply this to some
problems but I'll specifically be
talking about the set of data structures
for which you obtain bounds which is
equal to the current diversity of the
graph so there are some structures which
obtain bounds with respect to the
maximum velocity that I obtain over the
rounds but for keyboarding composition
we need we need to have the current
uh bounce
so for this structure is a level data
structure uh because you're partitioning
the vertices across levels of the
structure so specifically you have log n
levels of the structure
and the vertices are moved up and down
the levels According to some rules so be
talking about insertions in this
presentation
um we also have a a more complex
procedure for deletions that you you'll
hear from Julian later on this week
um but for insertions uh you can also
model this as kind of a peeling
algorithm if you're familiar with that
literature
so the way that vertices are moved is
that you assume that each vertex which
is initially adjacent to an edge update
is active
and what you want is you want to move
the active vertices
so I've shown an example here for this
example you can assume all of the edges
are inserted into the graph so the graph
is initially empty or assuming all the
edges are inserted as one batch into the
graph
so all the vertices are initially active
and for each active vertex you want to
look at this quantity of is induced
degree in the same and higher level
Neighbors
let's take a look at this example
for this example the induced degree of
each of these yellow active vertices is
given here
now if the induced degree exceeds the
threshold up here so 2.1 has one plus
ETA then you move the vertex up so
supposing that ETA equals 0.1 we move
all the vertices with degree greater
than 2 up
so these set of vertices move up
now vertices we move up uh remain active
vertices which did not move up become
inactive
so once you've moved up the vertices you
find the new induced degree for the new
active vertices and you keep moving them
up if they exceed the threshold
so you can iteratively do this for every
level starting from the bottom most
level
until you reach this graph
so the terminating condition is either
you reach the topmost level in your
iteration uh or all the vertices
becoming active
so for this example this is the graph
you give with this cutoff
now one observation I want to make here
is that you somehow want to obtain the
approximate core number from this data
structure
so one observation here is that vertices
in the highest level have core numbers
approximately equal to the cutoff for
the structure so vertices in the top
level have approximately within factors
of two of the cutoff for for this
structure
now we can do then is that you can stack
copies of the structure on top of each
other
and for each of these copies you have
cutoffs which increase by a factor of
one plus Ada
so you want o of log n copies of these
structures uh where the bottom structure
has a cut off 2.1 times one plus Ada and
the topmost structure has 2.1 times 1
plus
ETA to the log n
cut off
and once you have the stack
the stack sure you can take the
approximation as the largest cutoff the
vertex is above the topmost level
so for the core number approximation you
look at the vertex and you look at the
group for which the vertex is above the
topmost level
of that group with that cut off and
that's your approximation for your core
number
of the 2.1 is that it's easy for
explanation that's a great question
um the 2.1 hash should be turned into
two plus any constant greater than zero
and it affects your approximation Factor
okay and this algorithm can be cast into
this uh locally adjustable algorithm
graph algorithm framework
um it can be cast relatively
straightforwardly
um where the state of each node is the
level that is currently on
every single time is the vertex needs to
compute the state
the neighbors send their current levels
to you
and then counting the number of
Neighbors at or above your current level
determines your new state
so that's a fairly easy cast of this
algorithm into this framework and now
let me talk about some of the uh
complexity measures we have for our
models
so we can implement this in the batch
Dynamic shared memory setting
uh with these complexity measures so we
get work efficiency which means that the
work matches the best amortized work per
update of the sequential algorithm best
known sequential algorithm and we get a
two plus Ada approximation two-sided
error with poly log depth
um so this patch Dynamic algorithm up
here can actually be made deterministic
with um a few extra log factors in the
depth so it can be a robust against the
strongest adaptive adversary
and the only randomization here is uh we
use hash tables so that's the only
randomization with this current depth
now almost immediately we can turn our
batch Dynamic shared memory algorithm
into an MPC algorithm
with these complexity measures
So currently there doesn't exist any
bash Dynamic NPC algorithm for this
problem but compared to the static
algorithm our number of rounds is
greater
so this is not highlighting in green
because we want to improve the number of
so we want the rounds to be at least as
good as the static number of rounds here
what is Delta ah Delta is any constant
greater than zero less than one so you
can work for any constant
in sublinear memory permission
um and we also obtain a local Edge
differentially private algorithm the
difference the two differences here is
we get an additive term
so the additive log n over Epsilon is
probably existing due to some lower
bounds for density sub graph which is
within a two factor of k-core the max
k-core number
but probably you can reduce this log to
something smaller
so that would be an open question and
the other difference is uh for local
HTTP we get two plus ETA one-sided error
so it's Q Plus 8 on one side not the
other side
okay
um and I want to conclude with uh with
my argument that the transformation to
the private level data structure is easy
um so we're actually working on some
implementations and the implementation
actually is quite easy just use Google's
DP package
um but you can tell me whether this
transformation is easy or not
uh so the way that we're transforming
this uh data structure is that recall
that we have some number of vertices
um this is a static algorithm in local
DB so we assume all of the edges are
inserted as one batch at the initial at
the start of the data structure
and then once you've inserted these
edges your
determining which of these nodes to move
up
now the only change that we make is that
when we're determining whether the
vertex moves up we draw this independent
noise from this geometric distribution
so the pmf is given here for the
geometric distribution
and uh
once you draw this noise
you add this noise to your induced
degree for your active vertex
and the sum of the noise plus the
induced degree determines whether your
vertex moves up
and that's it so the only difference is
algorithm means the same you add this
noise to determine whether the vertex
moves up or not
and then everything else is the same you
draw new noise every single time a
Vertex remains active you add this noise
determine whether and then determine
whether they add a noise plus the
induced degree excuse the threshold
Etc
approximation is using the maximum
cutoff sp4
and that's it that's the only
transformation for the algorithm
analysis it's a different story but the
algorithm at least is just this
and in terms of open questions
we
Pro maybe can uh
get better approximation factors for the
batch Dynamic results
so this is a two plus Ada two-sided
error
um so four plus Ada one-sided error
probably decrease the approximation
while maintaining the depth and
amortized time
MPC we definitely want to reduce number
of rounds
so at least getting the number of rounds
for the static setting
uh and for local HTTP probably you can
reduce the additive error as I mentioned
before there are some lower bounds for
density sub graphs um that states that
probably the log n over Epsilon probably
will stay but decreased number of logs
probably possible
um the two plus Ada unfortunately so
this paper gives a lower Bound for login
rounds so two plus Ada if you want login
rounds probably needs to stay
and finally
um for the larger question
um you will we would like to see what
other problems can be solved in
different settings with algorithms that
can transfer easily between the models
and which problems encounter barriers
uh and that's it
um
happy to take any additional questions
[Applause]
thank you very much for this that
presentation
um other questions comments
so
that's a little question yes is it
possible that there's like um
original set of algorithmic Primitives
so that if you
you know express your algorithm in terms
of these Primitives yes then they
translate and looks like you identified
some some things but is it at the level
of you know here's the programming
language use this and everything yes
that would be great that would be great
as um as an end goal
um identifying some programming
Primitives such as if you satisfy these
and you satisfy all of these models so
what we've done is um we've shown that
these are locally adjustable graph
algorithms there's some easy
transformation to private algorithms in
the local model
um but even for that we don't have
approximation guarantees for these
algorithms we're currently working on
that
um but we in the grand scheme of things
we want something like this either a
universal model that covers all the
models or some sort of Primitives that
allow you so if you satisfy this
primitive you get these
guarantees and XYZ models
yeah I think I directly have a question
about that you you showed this long list
of problems right so are you saying now
for all of them you can do something and
look with the people so some of these
problems that's a great question
um so some of these um problems are it's
difficult to Define for differential
privacy like matching is actually
difficult to Define
um as a problem for for privacy because
if you output the matching that violates
privacy Well Valley is Edge privacy
um at least so for these the problems
I've shown density sub graphs lower
degree ordering and k-core decomposition
we have private algorithms for the other
ones are upper graphs
foreign
yes
what about if you only wanted to Output
the size of the matching yes
yes uh for size of the matching local DP
um currently we don't have an algorithm
for size of the matching for local DP
but I think that's much more tractable
and can you also say a little bit about
why the additive error is poly
logarithmic even ah yes ah definitely so
log Square n over Epsilon comes from um
let me go back to this slide here
okay so logs for n
it comes from this parameter that we
passed into the geometric mechanism
so this is this directly this directly
uh it translates to a log Square n over
f y r
um the additional log that we have is
for high probability
so our approximation bounds are given in
terms of high probability this parameter
gives you a log Square n times Epsilon
Times log n for the high probability
approximation
are there any other questions
um do you mind going back to the last
slide
yeah so for
the the two plus eight at the bottom
um you said there's a lower Bound for
login rounds if you were to do like
polylog instead okay is it like can you
can you beat that two plus Ada
um I forget exactly whether the lower
bound here is for poly log rounds I
think it is tied to log n
so if I recall correctly if it is tight
if I recall correctly it's tied to login
that that's still open
okay good let's thank the speaker again
[Applause]
there's now a break and the next talk is
at 11 45.